and these sisters really proved it I
don't know what age they were but
they're Ukrainian sisters were arrested
for twerking on the graves of Fallen
Soldiers they are facing uh five years
in prison so these chicks twerked on the
graves of Fallen Soldiers and guys
unfortunately this is not the first time
I've seen something like this I have
seen what I have seen women working at
funerals I have seen women
um working on a casket I have like women
will use our sexuality for political
reasons
um or just for stupid reasons like this
um I don't know why on Earth you would I
don't know why on Earth you would go and
work on the graves
of soldiers that fought for their
country it's like the audacity